hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
um and i'm just checking in on you
and if you're you're you're someone who
listens
regularly to this podcast you're
probably thinking yourself hey bill
what's with the quiet glum
[__] tone
this is not why i listen to this podcast
i listen to this podcast for laughs
so why don't you pick up the energy
and dance you bald
orange freckled monkey
huh
um everybody's asleep upstairs so i
gotta i gotta be quiet here
um
speaking of orange monkeys
everybody you must have seen that
[__] video it was all over the gram
as the kids call it the gram
uh actually
nobody's like on instagram anymore oh my
god
everybody's on it's like all about tick
tock tick tock that was like so [__]
two years ago
you [__] social media [__]
i love how people like keep you know i'm
not even on facebook anymore like that's
like a [__] status thing now
oh really
is facebook not cool enough for you yet
you know what they like they like those
[__] jerk off club kids
are there even clubs anymore
you know or do you just go on amazon and
you order [__] that you'd see in the
club and it comes right to your house
and you have your own club in your house
i love how [__] are doing that now
everybody's just [__]
he's [__] dad tell you these goddamn
kids today they don't even [__] go
out and go buy toothpaste
they [__] order it through amazon and
then some [__] idiot
pulls up on a giant ups truck and hands
you a tube of toothpaste
i mean is there any wonder why there's
so many fat [__] kids out there
you know what i mean
just a bunch of [__] lard asses with
like
jacked zero percent body fat fingers
from [__] typing on that keyboard
ordering goddamn cupcakes they [__]
their bodies were in this [__] shape
their fingers are
from copying and pasting and hashtagging
and they're f whatever oh jesus he's
extra grumpy tonight um
yeah all these [__] social media
[__] what at what point are you gonna
get some self-esteem
and just realize that you know it's just
the same [__]
going from [__] platform to platform
oh is that where the cool kids are now
think about it
think how many times you put on your
hoary makeup
and got on friendster
and then you went on [__] facebook
and then myspace
and then facebook opened it up to
everybody and then oh the [__]
parents ruined it
[__] ruined facebook right
and then where'd you go vine was that
the next one
twitter was somewhere in there
i just remember comics going oh dude
you're on twitter yet you got to get on
twitter
are you on vine dude vines the next
thing duty on instagram i stopped at
instagram
i'm just gonna grow old with my
followers on instagram
like some [__] old vegas act
every couple of years you just move down
to a smaller and smaller room
see it literally
you know
gets to the point people are checking
into the hotel and they can take in your
show while they wait for their turn to
get their [__] keys
you're standing over there in the corner
you know welcome to harrah's
welcome to o'shea's everybody
congratulations you hit rock bottom
you hit rock bottom right and then you
[__] you're making those jokes and
then
you get reprimanded
uh we got some complaints from some of
the uh
customers that you were making them feel
bad about staying here
do you have a comment on that yeah i do
have a comment on that you have dollar
craps
all right stop acting like you don't
know what the [__] you're attracting
here
roach has skipped this [__] place did
you guys ever go to o'shea's
should have called it oh jesus
sorry um
oh shays
it was this [__] casino renisto i
used to work the improv at harris way
back in the day there's no improv there
anymore
i used to work there and this guy used
to come out on a [__] unicycle with
makeup on
to that [__] song
you all ready for this
and i just remember him in between shows
just nice as can be just sitting there
you know with his [__] makeup on in
his goddamn unicycle
and the level of depression that i had
to fight off because he was such a
[__] nice guy and i'm like what this
[__] business did to this guy
and and and and
and he'd get out there and he'd be
[__] hopping up and down on that
[__] thing
putting on this show you know the thing
where you pedal forward and backwards
you know so you don't [__] tip over
14 times i would watch that guy two
shows tuesday
two shows wednesday two thursday two
friday two saturday two
sunday was nothing longer than that
[__] week
oh my god my favorite time
during those weeks at harrah's was like
the second i said goodnight on the
second show
and it was just like oh my god let's get
out of this [__] casino
and i would just go with the other actor
he would just get the [__] out of there
and uh the unicycle guy was old so he
wouldn't hang with us
i forget his name he's a real nice guy
you know he'd be taking his [__]
makeup off as you were getting ready to
do your second show all right man take
it easy
he would leave
and you go and go do your [__] show
and this is back when people gamble too
so the shows were quick that was the one
thing
get him in and get him the [__] back on
the floor
and we walk out and every once in a
while you just go next door to that
[__] o'shea's
great thing about o'shea is you could
gamble like james bond
meaning you you could sit there for like
a [__] hour and not go broke
because it was so cheap
that was the first thing i learned first
time i took my wife to a casino
i sat down to play i don't know i think
i was playing craps or something
a roulette one of those dumb ass games
and you just show up and like within
five minutes you've lost all your money
and you're like where's the part where i
sit down on my white tuxedo
and they come over and offer me a drink
for nothing when the [__] does that
happen
like how much money do you need to have
at these [__] places you know
so uh i used to go over the [__]
o'shea's og
and you could sit there
and [__]
gamble for like an hour or whatever
until it was boring
um i'll go over to caesars dude i've
been doing it long enough i was out in
vegas
before that tiger attacked that guy
like they were across the street
siegfried and roy
rest their souls were still doing shows
when i first came out danny ganz
was still alive
the amount of [__] people that died
since i started oh my god this is
getting dark
y'all ready for this
that was the the like in the 90s that
was the let's get the party started
[__] song
there was a few clubs
that just had these songs that they
would play
to start the shows
and they just [__] played them
forever
and you'd come back you know you
wouldn't play the club for two years
and they get ready to start the show and
they play the same theme music and
you're like they're still playing this
like i remember the comedy connection
at faneuil hall
used to play this guitar instrumental
that white cliffs of dover
[Music]
i don't know what it was it was like a
[__] mormon
a virgin mormon right before he has 28
wives right would [__] if he wrote a
guitar solo like that's what it would
sound like
um it was just [__] i don't even know
what it was
it was weird it was like upbeat and
happy
which none of the music i was listening
to at that time
i don't i can't even explain it was just
like
maybe it's i think it has more to do
with me than the poor bastard that wrote
that [__] song
i just want to say i did did you have
any pain in life
like what in the [__] am i listening to
right now
maybe it's one of those people that had
like so much [__] pain that his this
thing was i'm just gonna bring joy to
people
like your brain you heard that song like
your brain just you couldn't think
anything after
so anyways and played that cl i mean
they played that like i was living in
boston when i started out
or outside of boston
and i used to give him [__] like even
back then
going are you ever going to change this
[__] song
it started off with that weird weenie
man man this [__] weird intro
some weird [__] like that
then i go ooh
i'm telling you [__] something like
that right
i just
threw like three different bookers of it
i think you guys ever going to change
this song and they would just laugh
thinking i was making a big deal out of
nothing
but they had no idea how [__]
depressing it was was to leave boston
and come back like a year later and
finally get a gig there
and they're still playing that [__]
song
still have the same carpet everything
got a little older
waitresses got older i got older
it just made you think about dying
um
if you're new to this podcast it's
usually not this [__] bleak or dark
but anyways all these [__] social
media [__] reminded me
of back in the day when i lived in um
new york
and it was right as paris and nikki
hilton were getting famous
and they were sort of writing about
these club kids these rich kids
you know
of manhattan social life it's not like
everybody down there was like you know
it wasn't like the hiltons were hanging
out with the [__] four season kids
and the
macy's
[__] cousins or whatever but like
whatever they were down there and i just
remember what always struck me as so
funny
was
there'd be a club and it would be the
hottest [__] thing ever and everyone
be a big [__] line
down the street all these who is all
these women dress like who is they
dressed like [__] prostitutes who's
kid no
you know what i mean remember back in
the day you'd see a prostitute walking
down the street
you would see him now
you probably see him but now they're
just dr everybody dresses like have
every [__] broad out there seems to
be dressing like i'm
walking around with no goddamn clothes
on what are you talking about bill i
don't know
just talking generally speaking
um
i mean yeah you just they just sort of
pushed it to the limit
of how you can dress up a vagina
seductively to the point now the only
place to go is to just walk down the
street with just heels on
um but anyways these [__] kids
they'd be all about this [__] place
right and then all of a sudden the place
across this new place across the street
would open up and then that was the
place
and then the other place across the
street
would slo would die
this slow death and it's just like
it's this but
it's the same jerk-offs you guys just
all walked across the [__] street
and they just sort of dressed it up
differently social media is like that
it's the same [__]
oh really bill have you figured out
social media you freckled [__]
i like to think i have
you
know anyway
so the latest news in my life
is the lights in my driveway right
they're like you know when i go out to
my garage i like them lit up because you
know this cow coyotes is a [__]
mountain lion i mean they [__] live
close by right
or whatever i don't even know if there's
mountain lions i have no [__] idea
the [__] hills this deer there's a
deer there's a bear
it's just you know or a [__]
something's eating that thing
[Music]
what does it do what is the purpose of a
[__] deer the purpose of a deer is to
feed a mountain lion or a bear
so if you see one of those [__]
things that's why if i see a bunch of
mice and [__] like that i know there's
snakes around
you know what i mean those are like
sliders for [__] reptiles so if you
you see those things around i
immediately like these [__] snakes
here i gotta get out of here everybody
focuses on the mouse
and they think that's the worst of your
problems it's not the mouse the mouse
sucks i'm not gonna lie to you they're
[__] fast as [__] though
i've had a few mice in my [__] house
in a day and like not only they fast
they're [__] quiet as [__] those
little [__] feet make no noise and
they haul ass
and
anyway it's not the mouse it's what the
[__] eats that thing
so if you have a mouse in your house
eventually you're gonna have a [__]
snake
so you have to catch that little [__] or
who's who's can who you have to hire
somebody
you know
now there's a [__] recession-proof
[__] job
right
rodent
and pest control
i don't care what the [__] economy is
people are not living with mice
they're not living with bugs they're not
living with that [__] i don't give a
[__] if they have to skip if they have
to eat for a [__] week
they will prioritize getting somebody
over there to spray carcinogens into the
air in their house
knowing that you're bigger
than the [__] mouse and the mouse is
going to die and you eventually will too
but not for a long [__] time and you
will live a mouse free existence
while those chemicals slowly do their
magic do
their job
which is to kill
um literally
they spray [__] i swear to god
they spray [__] in your [__] house
that is probably banned by nato
you know you can't drop it on a city but
you can drop it in your own house
take out some
[__] goddamn rodents um anyway so the
latest thing
so i like having the lights the driveway
you know what i mean i want to see
what's going to kill me
i just don't want to sense that there's
something there it's my big fear of the
ocean it's not that i it there's sharks
it's that i can't see them that's what i
don't like you know what i mean it's not
that it's a i you know
anyway
so i'm getting the guy to fix these
[__] lights
you know because i tried to do it and
failed miserably
and the lights are just the cheapest
shittiest [__] as i don't know who
the [__] redid this house 20 years ago
but this was a flip is what i finally
[__] realized
and anyways the guy tells me he goes
into my wall
and he goes yeah you know i undid the
light bulb
and i took it out and light was still
shining through the hole
and i was like what's going on here why
am i seeing light and he said do you
realize this wall is not really a wall
like there's no cinder blocks in here
this is like plywood it's like a hollow
wall that they put plaster over
and i swear to god if i ever meet the
[__] guy
like he's gonna give a [__]
if i ever meet the guy who flipped this
[__] house i don't know who it was
but in my fantasy
i meet him
and i tell him
what a soulless
heartless cheap [__] he is
and it actually registers in my fantasy
and he actually feels bad
which in reality
i know would never happen
he wouldn't give a [__] he would
actually get enjoyment probably
i'm assuming it's a he because i'm
progressive and i believe women and
women don't lie and when they flip a
house they actually put
concrete cinderblocks in the walls
because
they are higher beings than us okay and
when they [__] on our beds
know that
you as a man made them do it
anyway
evidently the celtics won tonight which
i'm very thrilled about but i did not
watch one second of the game why bill
i'll tell you why
because
i mentioned this
i did the bottom of the first of the red
sox angels game the other day
and the uh
the announcer uh dan o'brien was asking
me you know if i was gonna watch you
know the celtics in the finals and stuff
and i basically told them
that i lacked
the emotional maturity
to watch my own team in the nba finals
when my kids are around
you know what i mean and i don't it's
like i don't want to be playing shoots
and ladders while screaming
my nba referee conspiracy theories
you know
about that [__] league i don't want
to do that i just had to make like a
judgment here like what do you want to
be here bill
do you want to be a good father
or do you want to be a basketball fan
you know so it's kind of a no-brainer
i'm like i'm just i'm not watching this
[__] i'll record the games
i'll find out who wins if the [__]
celtics lose i'm still gonna watch the
game but i'll watch it after i know what
the [__] gonna happen and then that
way i don't have to die a thousand
deaths
and sit there screaming and yelling
at the [__] i don't want to sit there
and watch the celtics
you know playing in an away game and
just
like hating some random guy from [__]
san francisco in the crowd who's miming
shooting a bow and arrow every time
[__] steph curry hits a three
like do i really want to do that to
myself is this making me happier
as a person
i mean if we win i guess it does but
like at the end of the day i don't feel
like freaking out my [__] kids so i
just like was like
i'm gonna just keep watching the red sox
i'm gonna watch game 58
and it doesn't matter
by the way red sox two games above 500 i
don't know if they won a loss tonight
but
um
considering where the hell we were we're
doing all right at this point um i think
we're just playing for the wild card
because i don't know if the yankees are
going to [__]
do worse than seven and three
every ten games they're playing like
seven of the ball they're [__]
killing it
um
so yeah i decided i was
not i was not watching that [__] i was
like [__] it
and uh
i heard it was an incredible game
but i
i enjoyed the experience of not watching
it
more i think than i'd and it's really
just the nba because i can handle the
nlp
and i can handle the nfl and i can even
handle the
nhl um
as much as the nhl drives me nuts as a
[__] leak but there's just nothing
like the nba
um
like you watch like i really feel like
the refs
through the first four games their job
is to make sure it's 2-2 and at that
point they're going to kind of let them
you know whatever at this point we know
it's going to go six
so let's not be overt about what the
[__] it is that we're doing here
and then they sort of let them play a
little bit
um
i mean just when you just look at like
some of the [__]
the games throughout the years like can
anybody like objectively
look at that game seven in 2009
um
when the lakers played the celtics
and they called 30-something fouls
on the celtics and like in the teens on
the lakers you just can't [__] do
that
in a game seven unless the other team is
literally taking out a two by four and
[__] smashing people over their head
with it
and they weren't
it was just they called ticky tack [__]
i remember that like kobe got shut down
that game
he had a terrible [__] game and in
the fourth quarter he shot 14 free
throws
rest his soul one of the greatest of all
time okay
but like i watched him take unguarded
shots
from the foul line
and it was like
it wasn't even basketball i might as
well just watch the [__] shoot around
they've had mobbed up reps they've had
all of this [__] everybody just [__]
like looks the other way whatever i i
you'll never get me
off of that ledge
that like the just any nba officials
literally dictate the pace of the game
speed it up slow it down it's [__]
ins i don't know how you watch that
sport
my hat is off to anybody who's a
die-hard nba fan
and can just sit there
year after year watching those raps just
[__] you
if there's no other sport
there is no other [__] sport where
the ref can just [__] they're in a
[__] mood if there's a guy on your
team that they don't [__] like
like the game you're gonna have to play
to come away with the victory every that
[__] allen iverson story
alan iris i forget what he said
something about the nba officials and
then they just started calling him
like [__] three games in a row four
games in a row they just call him for
carrying and traveling and all of that
[__] that he was doing every night
and after like the third or fourth game
he looks at one of the reps and he just
goes how long is this gonna last
and the guy goes how long is what gonna
last and he goes you know what i'm
talking about and the guy smiled
and then it was it
they they showed the authority
that they had over him and he had to get
his mind right like [__] cool hand
luke
and then they let him play his game
again but it's just like i just don't
know that there's another sport where
you that you can that effectively
[__] over a star player like the nba
reps all right i'm done i'm sorry
all right
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm just a guy who
real who thought he he purchased a house
that was built properly and he found out
that it's actually [__] made out of
legos maybe that's what it is
maybe it has nothing to do with the refs
and it just has to do with the fact
that
you know
i'm putting lights in a wall so i can
see
coyotes and [__] mountain lions that
if they had half a [__] brain would
realize they could just sort of just
push down my wall anyway if they wanted
to if they really wanted to
they could [__] organize
you know what i mean
get a little bit of [__] respect in
their goddamn lives
um
anyway
speaking of social media i was watching
this [__] clip of this gorilla
that [__]
it met a gopher or some [__] i don't
know what the [__] it was and i don't
mean to go for like on a construction
job
some guy [__] dragging the [__]
the goddamn roof shingles up to the
[__]
carpenters up top god knows i did that
goddamn job
i mean like an actual gopher
a real one
so the gorilla meets the thing right
and he was super like gentle with it
it was like you know
slash also kind of like apprehensive
like is this thing gonna bite me
and then all of these [__] we're
talking about and you know these animal
lovers
you know who think like sharks have
feelings
have you seen those videos where
somebody takes a fish hook out of a
[__] shark's mouth
and then they make these videos of the
sharks swimming up to him
and being like hey man i remember you
i [__] remember you thanks for taking
that shark that [__] fish hook out of
my goddamn
shark mouth
and like everybody's just like
see these sharks have feelings
and i'm just thinking like
well okay
but is that a real friend
you know i mean it's like if you didn't
do that for him that shark would try and
[__] eat you
so like that's that's that's the kind of
person a shark is
it's like if you don't help me out
through a hardship in my life i will
bite your leg off when you're in the
ocean
uh yeah i i don't think i need something
like that in my life but i also i don't
get mad at sharks
i respect them okay and i respect their
territory and i really
in my heart of hearts truly believe we
have no [__] business
being in the ocean
other than frolicking
along the [__] coasts but we
shouldn't be dumping our [__] out there
we should be living with it
and coming up with a solution for it
and
you know if you're a scuba diver you're
an [__]
you're an [__]
like leave them alone
i'm just [__] with you guys i'm just
[__] terrified of the ocean like i
tell you right now [__]
cave divers
i i it's like
jesus christ it's like
how bad are you
at talking to women
that you have to [__] cave dive
you know what i mean just so you have
something to talk about or hopefully
somebody talks hey
that's uh that's uh mikey mikerson over
there you know he he does cave diving
you know like women don't give a [__]
about that
you know if you cave dived and you
[__] found some buried treasure
you know on a regular basis then all the
[__] would come running
um god it's so cynical
it's just really cynical tonight i don't
know why
um
i saw a beautiful ford f-250 today
the four-wheel drive
it's all white
i hate that they don't offer more colors
in the f-250s
you know what i mean like the f-150s
have all the [__] colors but every
one of those [__] trucks is four
doors i hate i [__] hate a four-door
pickup
it's so [__] it's like a [__]
giant station wagon
except you don't have the cap on the
back then you have that little stupid
six-foot bed
what are you gonna put half an l-shaped
couch back there like what the [__] is
that for
you know what i mean get a four-door
sedan or buy a [__] truck
i i will go to my grave scene a [__]
pickup truck is two doors with a bench
seat in an eight-foot bed
you know
you know unless you get older
and you get older then you get the
[__]
the two-door with the bench seat and the
six-foot bed
and then that's trucks for like hot
rodders and then like old guys
that's the truck version of like the
three-wheeled motorcycle
you ever see that
some old hell's angel
he's gonna ride till he dies but now
he's just he's got [__]
sciatic nerve issues going down both
legs
so he's got to have like the [__]
tripod thing he rolls down the street
i used to ride on two wheels now i'm on
three
that ratty [__] braided ponytail
you know
his [__] tattooed wife with her
[__] skin damage
still showing that [__] stamp how about
a shout out to women who still have
[__] stamps who didn't get him covered
up
who aren't embarrassed that they came of
age in the 90s
you know who have the courage
to have their tattoo let the world know
that they backed into a lot of dick when
clinton was in office you know
i respect that
um all right let's do some reads here
some advertising
oh look who it is everybody oh it's
simply safe
simply safe like riding a three-wheeled
motorcycle
those giant dumb fenders
um
by the way i thought like they ruled out
those things
well they used to have the honda atc
they used to kill like [__] 20 kids
in every town when i was growing up um
simply safe everybody you know
guys
you know
i can't even read this you guys know i
love the break-in protection that my
simply safe home security system gives
me
yeah i got one of the cameras right on
my cardboard [__] wall
um but it's not always
outside forces that you need simply safe
protection from meet amy
amy
what the [__] happened to
you did someone break in that was
related to you
why do you need cameras inside your
[__] house meet amy a simply safe
customer and a chronic sleepwalker
who lives near a four-lane highway
holy [__] did was she aware of her
[__] problem before she [__]
signed that lease
jesus christ i'm suicidal i just bought
a penthouse [__] apartment
um one night a few months ago she slept
walked out of her bedroom and then
continued right out the front door
a minute did she unlock the door at what
point are you awake
that is a dangerous situation dude have
you ever [__] dated a chick that
sleep walks that's gonna be the scariest
thing scariest thing
ever it's like you're dating that chick
from the ring
um
anyways oh here's the most obvious
sentence of copy i've ever read
that that is a dangerous situation
she could have been heading for a big
accident can you imagine driving down
the street you're [__] half asleep
after we're gonna double shift
some [__] white chick comes out and
you're [__]
dressed like ebenezer you know you know
that long shirt people used to walk with
that [__] hat just walking barefoot
muttering to herself
um
i want to say there was a horror movie
that started like that anyway she could
have been headed for a big accident
luckily as she walked out of her house
the simply safe entry sensor on her
front door triggered
the 95 db decibel siren
in the base station that is loud
god damn right it is loud enough in fact
to wake her up
before she wandered into the street or
some other trouble
oh my god this poor woman
how the [__] do you go to sleep after
that
you wake up to an air raid siren
standing in the shrubs
hey amy you're looking a little tired
this morning
uh seconds later amy even got a call
from simply safe checking to make sure
that everything was okay
amy was a little groggy i believe she
was probably two glasses of wine in
before she had that [__] phone call
but she was just fine
amy actually says
that on that sleepy night simply safe
saved her life well good for them
protecting
jesus i would like [__] tie myself to
the bed
uh protecting people is ways they never
protecting people in ways they never
could imagine is just one of the reasons
more than 4 million people use and love
simply safe
if you have sleep apnea does it set off
that 95 decibel [__] alarm
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simply safe dot com slash burr
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus 20 percent off
with interactive monitoring
dude she should have like one of those
[__] leashes you know
back in the day when people would have
their dogs in the backyard and they'd go
running
running after you and they'd reach the
end of their leash and get [__] yank
back by their neck
uh go to simplysafe.com
all right
and with that that is the podcast here
everybody
i hope you enjoyed it that was a fun one
i was in a stupid mood um
yes leave the page how many times i'm
gonna click on this [__]
um
please enjoy the music
uh
and there's gonna be a uh i don't know
what
a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast after this so you're
gonna get another half hour of content
okay
see that
not all redheads are the spawn of the
devil don't ever forget that but i
wouldn't trust us all right have a great
weekend you [__] and i'll check in on
you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday june 9th
one day before my [__] birthday
happy birthday to me
oh happy birthday to me
happy birthday you
[Music]
happy birthday
you
[__] douche what's going on how are
you i've watched a bunch of sports this
week that's all i did
that's all i did you know how many times
i sat through the national anthem whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
everybody's different version of it
you know
i gotta go with harry carey just sing
the goddamn song
just [__] get on with it
just drop the [__] puck
just throw up the basketball throw out
the first pitch
can we do like a trade-off like every
other game we just say we pledge
allegiance can we do that we can all
murmur it in the crowd i pledge
allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
i got choked up there one nation under
god indivisible
individual indivisible i don't know with
liberty and justice for all
you know well for most people
and for others more so than than than
not
you know depending on you know skin
color and uh what family you were born
into what part of the country right
if your parents were bankers you know if
your parents bought a fifty thousand
dollar fl plate of uh [__] trout
at an obama rally whatever whatever
those [__] politicians do
those filthy stinking bastards
i'll tell you they're all a bunch of
[__] liars
all right
we're all liars aren't we
i'll speak for yourself bill
um
i'm behind on everything i don't even
know what's going on in the world i keep
seeing this [__] about [__] i thought
i i thought that this oh [__] don't do
this to me this [__] computer come on
man
here we go what is this this
bergdahl
isn't there like also a place like
bergansi that everybody's freaking out
about
i really pay attention to like
national and international events
the way my wife watches sports which is
you just sort of walk by the tv
and if the same kind of if the same
athlete is on enough
she'll just be like oh yeah he's good
he's good i do that with international
stories like oh that's uh a lot of
people are uh talking about that
there was like i guess there was an
embassy that was bombed
no jesus
i wanna i wanna [__] read the
national news so this bergdahl guy
thought he'd say his name all i remember
was at some point there was some [__]
guy who looked like he was on duck
dynasty
speaking arabic and everybody got all
freaked out and obama was standing there
looking uncomfortable and i guess some
guy got released
from prison and everybody's [__] mad
because his dad
spoke arabic at the white house and
claimed the white house
you should see the guy
this guy that they think just claimed
the white house for islam
this guy looks like uh did you ever see
that episode of honey boo boo where the
people were all sitting in that [__]
room with one light bulb
bidding on food that had already expired
that's what this guy looks like
i don't think he [__] i don't think
the white house has anything to worry
about
you know can everybody just [__]
relax
the guy they said they stuck him in a
shark cage
he's so [__] like
out of it from his captivity he's
calling like it's just basically a cage
it's not a shark cage
how to [__] with the taliban get a shark
cage
you know in the middle of afghanistan
jesus christ where did they drag that
thing in from
the [__] black sea i mean come on
people tip your weight staff over there
you know something
the [__] taliban works out on a
jungle gym as far as i remember from the
last newscast that i watched about 15
[__] years ago or maybe it was 10 i
don't know
they work out on a jungle gym where
where the [__] are they gonna get the
money for a shark cage to have that
thing flown into afghanistan like they
have some sort of international airport
if they have one we built it
right we built it so we could land there
you know
try to slap them around and give them a
bucket of kfc to let them know what the
good life's about
right
you guys see that i just saw a
commercial um
uh for kentucky fried chicken where the
parents are all excited because the two
bratty kids won't sit still
at the dinner table but they got him
this [__] chicken
and they're feeding it to him they're
basically very subtly saying that
there's drugs in this chicken
that will make your [__] children
chill the [__] out and [__] i mean
like you know not not the way they mean
it over there in great britain
you can't say that on the comedy or you
can say it in a comedy club over in
scotland but you'll have a rough you'll
have a rough go of it if you say the kid
was [__]
over there that means like severely uh
mentally challenged
over here it just means you're not going
to get laid to your 26.
when you're in grad school
looking over a [__] cadaver
right with some other [__] nerd nerd
right and you're just sitting there
going you know the ankle bones connected
to the knee bone right
has any of this made any sense well it
shouldn't it's [__] sunday night and
i am spent and i got a whole bunch of
[__] i have to do tomorrow so i got to
do it tonight
all right i'm off my game
all right i got to do i got to talk to
the regular guys tomorrow one of my
favorite radio shows out there i got to
talk to them tomorrow morning
but you guys are probably listening to
this i've already done it to hype my
show in atlanta
at the tabernacle two shows
i'm taping there for my next stand-up
special and i gotta tell you i got a lot
of not a lot of a lot of [__] eyebrow
raisin when i've been talking to other
comedians where you taping i go atlanta
they go atlanta
really they got good crowds down there
they got great [__] crowds down there
it's going to be an even better show
because i'm gonna be going to i mean i
wish i was going even further into the
south you know be a great special i
should have taped it in like [__]
macon georgia
and then when i went up there and i did
my bit about how i want to get a 22
caliber that's all i want to protect my
house and watch those [__] backwoods
people lose their goddamn minds
that adds a whole another layer to the
joke
right
who the [__] knows i don't know but i'm
gonna be down there
um
i gotta hype the show to sell the last
remaining tickets um to the special i
hope you guys uh come out to the show
should be a uh should be a goddamn hoot
nanny that's what the [__] it should be
um
all right so what's going on in the
world what did i do this week i didn't
[__] do anything completely lost my
train of thought i didn't do [__] this
week all i did was i watched sports and
it was great because you had the uh the
nhl in the nba finals and they so far
they've been on different nights
so i've watched every second every of of
all of them
because i have no i don't really have a
life right now i'm just kind of sitting
here waiting for june 20th
when i take my special that's all i'm
waiting for once i get past that
once i get past that all right
oh billy boy here oh freckles
is [__] i'm go i'm falling off the
wagon in a big way
all right
i've been on the [__] wagon right now
for 52 [__] days
and i've had it all right you cleanse
your liver in like 42-43 days or
something like that every drunk i know
has told me that every drunk i know
that does not have a medical degree has
told me
that if you go 42-43 days you will
cleanse your liver at least to the booze
you know now if you [__]
you start doing blow or uh you know
eating a bunch of trans fat [__] food
or feeding your kids kentucky fried
[__] chicken
jesus christ what happened to parents
that you got to drug your kids to keep
them under control
you know
you know what kids don't respect their
parents they respect them but they don't
respect like oh my god this this person
could ring my neck
could pick me up by my hair
right could grab a paddle
and [__] you know
mostly hit my ass but also kind of hit
my lower back because i'm squirming
right
that doesn't exist anymore so now these
kids are so [__] out of control these
people have to go down a kentucky fried
chicken
okay and i i use the term chicken very
loosely
to go down
in whatever that is that's in that
bucket
okay
if it doesn't have a beak it doesn't
have feet if it's [__]
you know
chester's it's breast is sticking out
like the cast on [__] uh what was
what was that show with the italians
there on new jersey short jersey shore
right
my world that's not a [__] chicken
you know you want the chicken that
looked like mark maguire in his rookie
season you don't want to eat the chicken
that looks like mark maguire when he
[__] played for the cardinals
you know
if you eat a regular [__] chicken
first of all it's gonna look like a
pigeon to you because you're so used to
seeing those roided up ones
that they have murderers row that you
got down there at your [__] shaws
right
your vons your jc pennies whatever the
[__] you buy your goddamn chicken
you go down you go down to any one of
the mainstream [__] supermarkets
okay
and i swear to god when you get to the
chicken section okay if you've if you've
slept for the last 30 years
like that van gundy guy under the bridge
whatever his [__] name is van
morrison the hell's his name
rip van winkle right that was one of
those people one of the vans
um
if you slept for the last 30 years and
you went down okay
and they showed you what a chicken was
you'd be like uh you'd be like that
ain't no chicken
okay it's a goddamn turkey i know a
[__] time i know a [__] turkey
when i see one all right
ain't no such thing as a nine pound
[__] chicken
can't be done no sir
no sir get off my property okay i'm i'm
done with your witchcraft okay
hey i think get the [__] out of here
[__] off my property
um
honey get the gun
yeah you would think it was a [__]
turkey and the thing is is now it's a
chicken and i remember i watched one of
those food inks one of those [__]
liberal goddamn things you know talking
about flying carpets and electric roads
and all that [__] somewhere in there
they were talking about you know the
food supply and how poison it is
poisonous
is
um
so i [__] went down to a farmer's
[__] market
and um
i said i wanna i wanna i wanna all i
want i wanna i want an all-natural
[__] chicken i can't even talk i'm so
tired i want an all-natural chicken
the guy goes these are all natural and i
said all natural and he goes well
i'm like come on where is it
and he had to walk around the corner
sitting over there
lonely
i swear to god
looking like a dove looking somebody
killed the [__] dove he goes right
there that one right there
is 100 all natural nothing's wrong with
it and i was like
i was like what what
that's what a chicken's supposed to look
like
and he raised his eyebrows
and he he kind of put his lips together
so they were a straight line and then he
nodded
you know i looked at people do like
like yeah i'm in the matrix i realize
i'm in the matrix but you know
i knocked the [__] up
so i gotta be selling these roared it up
chickens no um
anyways i know what the [__] i'm talking
about so basically that's what these
people are eating over there okay they
are they are drugging up
their kids but i can't get mad at them
because i actually did that
to charlie murphy
and uh don l rawlings i've told this
story before hey i'll tell it again it's
my [__] podcast i actually drug the
exact thing that they're doing in that
kentucky fried chicken commercial
where they're trying to get their kids
to sit still by just feeding them so
full of these [__] trans fats from
these roided up beakles [__] chickens
with their dolly parton breastuses
right
i did that
to [__] donnell and charlie i was
hungover
and we were taking a car service from
chicago zaney's up to one of those
whenever the [__] it was
saint charles
it was a three city run
and one of them was saint charles so
we're getting in the [__] limo
don ellis in rare form charlie's in rare
form they're [__] gabbing and
trashing people and me and everybody and
i just don't want to hear it i'm like i
don't want to listen to these [__]
guys
running their goddamn yaps in the back
of this car the whole [__] way up i
want a nice quiet ride
this is gonna suck and i walked outside
hung over
and i walked into the chicago where you
know almost got hit by three fat people
and um
i looked up the street and i saw it i
saw popeyes
and i was like oh thank god
and i [__] walked in there and i got
all this [__] popeye's chicken with
biscuits
and all of this [__] food
and i brought it back to the car
and as the car pulled up they came out
and i said hey guys i got to sell some i
got us some food
and they were ah that's [__] great
you know they were hungry or whatever
and they started chowing that [__]
popeye's food and i sat back nibbling on
a drumstick
and i swear to god
ten minutes later they were asleep
i'm not lying to you they were [__]
asleep
snoring the whole way up and i was just
sitting there loving life the whole
[__] ride up and i you know what i
admitted to him later they thought it
was funny but that's basic what it is
they called it the itis
that's what they call it when you eat
that [__] food and then you have to go
to sleep they call it the itis i guess
and by they i mean african-americans
um
they call it the [__] itis and that's
what they got they and i learned that
from don l
because i don't know how that man stayed
in shape but he had the worst diet he's
one of those guys who like you stop for
gas and he comes out of the gas station
with like one of those gas station hot
dogs
[Music]
and he would eat it and then he would
immediately fall asleep
and like and i would say to charlie look
at this guy where he's sleeping and try
to be like yeah man he got the itis
and he explained that to me and with
that little bit of information
it went into my evil white brain
and i drugged my two african-american
friends
way back
in the year 2005.
um and that's a little chicken story for
you what how'd you like that everybody
so that's what the [__] they're saying
right there that's what kentucky fried
chicken
is allegedly saying i guess i have to
say alleged
so their lawyers on retainer
don't attack my [__] podcast
as far as i can tell i'm asking you
right now
um kentucky fried chicken
hiding behind your [__] letters kfc
is that what the [__] you do is that
what you're saying
if you got kids who are not stimulated
enough that they can't even sit down if
you haven't you gotta run them around
you gotta tire your kids out open the
door you send them out in the [__]
yard go ahead go outside get outside and
play
that's what you do like a goddamn one of
those [__] irish dogs
that was bred to to herd sheep you gotta
let that [__] thing run around
run around in circles go ahead get out
there
take a ball you just [__] throw it
out in traffic and let that dog run
around dodging cars it comes in it's
going to lay down
okay it's not going to jump all over
companies sticking its cold nose right
in their [__] hoo house
that's what you got to do with your kids
you got to send them outside
right but to catch a predator and all
these other [__] shows
you know all these shows on tv where
people forget their kids are in a car
with their windows rolled up
their kids are too [__] dumb to roll
them down or they're too weak because
they haven't gone outside and climbed a
[__] tree and they stay in there and
then their brains get cooked like a
boxer
you know
you know that dog boxes they know they
don't do well in the sun we'll need to
do fat kids
if you leave the windows rolled up you
know and they got those weak arms
that all the like the most tedious
things they ever did was take a wrapper
off of a [__] uh an ice cream
sandwich
right
you can't leave them in the car
my mother left us in the car all the
[__] time she would go to school she
was going to school during the day
trying to further her education and she
left five [__] kids in the car
with the windows rolled up and money for
burger king and she would say to us just
go into the burger that's the only time
you were to leave this car over the last
over the next three
[__] hours when i'm in class
and she would disappear around the
corner after we said absolutely mom
and she walked away and uh we
immediately would get out of the car
start walking up and down the streets in
boston
we'd go into [__] burger king and
we'd we'd have something to eat do you
know what would happen nowadays if they
just saw five [__] dirty face kids
walking up and down comm ave
boylston street going into a burger king
looking like the cast of [__] annie
someone would have filmed it and my
mother would have been they would have
taken us away
you know but but they didn't
because there was no cameras back then
or videotaped ones i mean there was
but only two people adam are like the
news
and a young stephen spielberg
so we went in there and we [__] got
some food
climbed on cars and [__]
yelled at people and [__]
you know hanging on parking meters and
all that hence we had the [__]
forearm strength to roll down the
windows and none of us ever had an issue
in the car and you know what i think
that's one to grow on
so there you go people i'm not saying
kfc
is food
i'm not i'm just kidding i'm not saying
it's bad food every once in a while
who's kidding who everyone's saying
would be great if you could just [__]
do heroin the way you can eat mcdonald's
just like every once in a while
he'd just be like you know what
yeah
let's just [__] tie off
not off for the rest of the [__] day
and like the people at work understood
it you know hey where were you yesterday
ah man yeah i got this black tower
heroin came in you know i hadn't done it
like three months away
figured [__] it
oh is that what you did how was it how
was it you know like you went to aruba
you said ah dude it was awesome [__]
i don't remember [__]
but you can't
you know you get addicted to it
um all right everybody let's do a little
advertising here shall we
shout out too [__] bad it's my
podcast i'm doing it anyways all right
here we go stamps.com everyone summer
is finally here
and you want as much free time as
possible don't let going to the post
office cut into that free time use
stamps.com instead with stamps.com you
can print postage right from your desk
you won't have to go to the post office
find parking wait for your turn all of
that crapola stamps.com turns your pc or
mac into your own personal post office
buy and print official us postage using
your computer or your printer print
everything from stamps to shipping
labels shipping labels wherever you need
whenever you need it oh my god
they just hand your mail and then just
hand your mail to the mailman stamps.com
is so convenient and easy to use you'll
never waste time going to the post
office again i use stamps.com to send
out all the crap that i sell at the end
of my shows when i stand there whoring
myself out
dealing with the [__] cougars
right with their red wine breath trying
to grab my lack of an ass uh right now
use my last name bur b-u-r-r for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer which includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
all right don't check in on your kids do
this click on the microphone on the top
of the home page and type in burr
b-u-r-r that's stamps.com enter burr
all right
who's number two in the order
uh dollar shave club everybody
the big razor companies you know what
they think we're stupid
oh yeah every year they roll out some
ridiculous shaving technology gimmick
and expect us to shell out big bucks for
it what are they up to 17 blades at this
point
all lifting and separating like a bra in
the 70s
do you really need a razor with a
vibrating handle huh a roller pivot ball
back scratcher egg timer laser pointer
corkscrew
huh i know i don't
we were shaving just fine before any of
that crap we were two blades that was
all you ever needed
um you could get it under your nose they
got so many blades you can't even shave
under your nose
um and i definitely don't think i need
to spend my hard-earned cash on it
people it's a bunch of junk if you're
sick of being treated like a fool like a
[__] like an idiot a [__] a sucker a
chump join the hundreds of thousands of
smarter people who join
dollarshaveclub.com
dollarshaveclub.com the best blades and
grooming supplies for just a few bucks a
month their blades are better than the
big shave companies for a fraction of
the price you know what i have sensitive
skin so watch what you say about it when
you're around it and their razors have
never given me any problems honestly i
have the best shave of my life with
their 4x razor you got to try it i've
never used that stop putting words in my
mouth i like the double blades you got
there sweetheart i told my buddy about
the dollar shave club that would be you
guys and he shares his subscription with
his wife no lie i think it saved their
marriage
dollar shave club why are you writing
all this crap you have a product that
sells itself
quit trying to make me sound more
personal all right
it's personal the way i [__] up the read
okay
my listeners can get started now at
dollarshaveclub.com
and don't forget next week is [__]
father's day
upgrade pop shave upgrade is
wait upgrade pop shave with the dollar
shave club gift card because he
shouldn't have to pay more for his
ridiculous shaving gimmicks either stop
getting ripped off by the big getting
ripped off by the big shaving companies
join dollarshaveclub.com
uh shave club duck what
oh they wrote it three times in a row
with no punctuation
dollarshaveclub.com
then it says shaveclub.com
i don't even understand what it is
dollarshaveclub.com that's what it is
b-u-r-r okay
this it's legitimate
we don't need any bells and whistles on
this thing just join it okay unless you
want to keep getting screwed
all right if you like to be gillette's
prison [__] keep doing what you're
doing oh god look at that look at that
little
thing i just opened up those are my
french words i stuck with it for two
months now i don't remember any of them
that makes a lot of people happy on the
podcast i knew you weren't going to
learn french
stay back here with me
in the towny bar
what is all of this crap
i have more [__] windows open where
the hell's the thing that i had here
ah jesus christ
untitled screenplay why don't i just
call it unwritten screenplay that i'm
never gonna finish
oh bill don't get down on yourself come
on
oh there it is okay
so anyways i've been watching a bunch of
sports over here
all this [__] week oh [__] you know
what's the greatest thing about the
finals right now two american teams
all right not that i'm against two
canadian teams i'm just against
listening to more than one national
anthem
all right i get it i like my country i
like living here i pay taxes pay the
roads
pay off a [__] do whatever you want
with my tax money i don't give a [__]
but for the love of god
how about we switch it up every once in
a while how about you play my country
tizithy
my country tears up the sweet land of
liberty of the icing
land of thy pilgrims wait
nice and quick
um
so what did i watch i watched the first
two games of the king's [__] ranges
um how about those rangers
huh
everybody thought the east was weak
including me
they're right there step for step stride
for stride skate for skate they've just
been snake bitten
in the in the overtimes i was really
hoping the rangers were going to win
game two you know because if they do
that's more hockey
i don't want the kings to sweep them
i don't want the rangers to sweep i
wanted to go seven games
i really do i i enjoy the goddamn sport
and uh i gotta tell you man it's been
two games i mean if you ever we're going
to get into hockey those are two [__]
great games to watch
uh both overtime games
i don't [__] i didn't know what to
tell you i can't even [__] remember
i've watched so much sports i don't
remember what happened all i know is the
rangers defenseman fell down in that
overtime and then williams scored
and uh i mean who the [__] scored game
two
i saw it i was watching it
it wasn't kopitar he's been snake bit
nah who the [__] knows all i know is
it's been great but i you know i'm
really hoping the rangers win game three
so we can get a series here but um
jesus christ the kings they don't give a
[__] huh down two nothing there whatever
we're used to it two nothing in a game
that's a joke we've been down three
games to none
they just sort of [__] just keep
playing the game you know what i also
like too about both games was when they
went into the uh the overtimes neither
team was playing like
like don't lose it hockey wait for them
to make a mistake they were just up and
down the ice [__] it
let's end this thing
um
really enjoyed that and as always i
can't stand them talking to the coaches
during the game i think it's
unbelievably disrespectful they did it
in the heat spurs game it was funny they
walked up to uh the spurs coach
what the [__] is his name bonneville i
have no idea i don't watch hoop
something with a b popovich
it was something like that either
sounded like a car or some [__] bad
junk food in the 70s
um
from the makers of jiffy pop comes
popovich
cracker jack's in your [__]
um pop popovich they this [__] lady
goes over there and she goes what are
your what's your plan in the fourth
quarter for uh
for lebron james and he literally looks
at he's like are you kidding me
uh try to get him to not score any
points
then she asked another dumb question he
looked at her like she had three heads
and then he just walked away and then
she laughed like she was in on the joke
rather than she was the joke
right you are the [__] joke
you're asking dumb questions it's not
her fault i'm sure they're piping them
into her ear
you know oh jesus christ how bad is the
[__] announcing crew for the nba
finals
mark jackson can somebody please explain
to me why
he always goes mama
there goes that man
what does that even [__] mean i know
it means something good
what does that mean am i too white to
understand that
is that is that's what said
when when a [__] giant guy walks down
the street in his part of the world
some little kid looks up at his mom
and says mama there goes that man i
don't even know what the [__] it means
all i can tell you is my my my newt
knowledge of basketball
watching that game i don't know
anybody's [__] name other than the
major people when that guy [__]
was dribbling baseline
and he threw the elbow into that guy's
[__] ribs he used to be married to
that chick that was on that show about
the desperate housewives
the [__] is tony parker yeah
and the [__] white guy
not van gundy the other guy mike breen
whatever when he goes i don't know
is that a foul who kind of looks like a
uh
you know a normal basketball movement
like it no it didn't
he made a fist moved his arm forward and
then brought his [__] elbow back it
was a textbook [__] elbow
like the day when they start making a
video version
right
of the dictionary because kids are too
fat to [__] read they can't hold
their eyeballs you know i don't know
going side to side is too much lateral
movement for their fat eyes
they should just have a video of that
was a textbook [__] elbow and they
actually sat there debating it
let's take a look at that again
yeah that's how i run
you know one's just sort of you know
going like you know my left arm just
kind of moves normally and then the
other one i don't know what it is
i don't know if i have a crooked spine
or whatever but it just kind of
it kind of moves you know [__]
all the way out straight and then it
goes back like that feels over the love
of god don't stand behind me textbook
[__] elbow
and then another thing that they did
that [__] bugged the [__] out of me
was when they go uh they were talking
about tim duncan they were showing this
great thing that when he first
met the guy there uh with the [__]
bald spot
uh
aaron brockovich whatever the [__] his
name is
chris googly ugly what's his name
i don't [__] know they said when they
first met him
and he also met tony paga
like he was
quiet and aloof and they were
intimidated by him
and they were telling the story it was
funny then they cut to tim duncan tim
duncan was like well you know i didn't
have anything to say to him you know
basically we're here to win games and if
we start winning games together we'll
build a relationship and then they come
back and mark jackson goes now you tell
me what what is the difference between
what he is doing not talking in to his
teammates and being aloof and what kobe
bryant does
and i almost fell off my [__] chair
and then jeff van gundy goes well you
know i think it's the media you know
once they get they think who you are
they just keep perpetuating it and blah
blah blah blah blah [__] blah that's
unbelievable
the excuses
that these nba [__] once you start
[__] sucking the dick
right of the nba like that's how you
make your [__] mortgage they just say
you know they're not going to criticize
the best guy well he's not the best guy
now because he's hurt but he's been the
best guy forever
some people would say [__] uh lebron
james whatever but you know what i mean
kobe's definitely
top three if not top two ever without a
[__] doubt not even debatable but
they just will not criticize the guy
and they're trying to say like tim
duncan's aloofness is the same as kobe
you know walking off the court during
bad losses walking out on his [__]
own teammates the whole shaquille o'neal
soap opera
you know and not to mention that bad
little [__] uh road trip he had
you know
out in colorado
i would think that yeah
you know i don't know
you know what's funny is i don't think
kobe gives a [__]
nor should he how the [__] people think
about him but they're sitting trying to
sit there and compare
tim duncan
you know acting like the way kareem
acted to magic johnson when he showed up
and started jumping up and down when
they won a [__] regular season game
and he sort of looked at him like
[__] relax we got 81 more games i
mean that's just what a veteran does
like that's the same thing as walking
off the court walking out on your own
[__] teammates
you know
i mean jesus christ jeff van gundy phil
jackson in his own goddamn book trash
kobe bryant in a roundabout way you
could read between the lines
uh he's definitely a difficult guy to
coach smash cut
to him ripping his tie off screaming at
his wife i mean how many championships
have i [__] won and his cut still
won't listen to me right that's what
he's really saying
how do you say go [__] yourself in
italian
that's what he's saying right
i i i really can't i i have a real
difficult time listening that looks like
a normal basketball motion tell me no
you told me what's the difference
between what he does what kobe bryant
there goes that man
i will tell you this though
um
that the nba finals don't look fixed
this year they're actually letting them
play and it's been very enjoyable to
watch
there's always going to be some [__]
fouls or whatever
and uh you know
i don't know who the dumb [__] was that
fixed the air conditioner though but if
lebron james has problems with cramps
you know it's probably in your best
interest to you know
a couple games i mean [__] you got home
court just have it be busted the entire
time
right
is anybody else annoyed during that
first game when the ac didn't work
watching all those people fanning
themselves in the crowd
you know didn't you learn in third grade
that that actually doesn't cool yourself
off
that actually just that motion alone is
raising your body temperature
making you sweat even more you know what
i think it is i think it's those those
[__] texas girls they wear so much
goddamn makeup
makeup right
that they gotta make sure you know
that it's not gonna run they're extra
[__] hot
you know they got a bunch of latina
women out there so a certain segment of
them have shaved off their eyebrows and
drawn them back on now you can't have
those things dripping down into your
eyes you can't do that courtside seats
right
on television so they're all sitting
there fanning them [__] themselves um
can anybody explain to me why why does
uh lebron
why does he get the cramps and nobody
else does why back in the day when they
would be playing in the boston garden
that had no air conditioning
right
and johnny most would be going triple
digits at the bastard garden it was like
over 100 degrees
and you see in kareem he's on the oxygen
and robert parish takes a sip to water
and then dumps the rest down the front
of his jersey
none of them cramped up
i don't understand
i guess everybody you know what that's
like lebron's
kryptonite i think if it gets too
[__] hot
so they ought to they ought to turn up
the heat on the heat there
that's what i would do
because lebron i mean look at the the
[__] guy's
guy's a goddamn adonis
he could body slam adonis whoever the
[__] that guy is is that some sort of
greek god who threw a discus in the nude
what the [__] was wrong with the greeks
and their goddamn naked games
right
everybody grappling over there
they're curly hair
i'm just [__] on everybody this week
aren't i oh whatever it's sunday night
did you guys go to church today
there was an ark and a bunch of lepers
make sure there's two
and that [__] [__]
and jesus won't throw a stone
um all right what do we got here 37
[__] minutes in
what have i have i talked about
everything oh yeah i'm still trying to
get in shape for my special i've sort of
like
leveled out
at about a buck 72 174 i want to be
about 170
so for the first time in a long time
because i [__] up my foot with that
plantar fasciitis there i actually took
out uh
uh
i don't know what to call it other than
a jump rope i know that's what girls
call it what do you call a
a skipping rope
i hadn't done in a few years jesus
christ oh my god
i should have videotaped it and i would
instantly be considered the funniest
human being ever
if you guys watch me try to remember
when to start jumping as i brought that
thing around
tell you it was ugly i only did it for a
minute because i'm testing out my foot
to see how it's going right so i did a
bunch of stretches and then i took a
tennis ball
and i rolled it around underneath my
foot before and after and it seems like
it's all right
but when you're old like me
it's not the day of and a lot of times
it's not even the next day it's that
next day it's the day after the day
after
all right because what you [__] up is
so deep down inside of you it takes a
while for it to get to the
surface what happened when i was playing
hockey god i haven't played hockey in a
while but i would [__] i would bruise
up like three days later
all of a sudden
it looked like i got caned this is
before i got all the pads
you know oh by the way i want to thank
all you guys for trashing me for my
cupcakes i really enjoyed
um
the cupcakes and i enjoyed the trashing
that you guys gave me i had a lot of
good laughs you know some hacky jokes
but you're trying you know it's not your
vocation there was a lot of funny ones
out there you guys you guys you know
what you paid it forward
you really entertained me
um
and i'm gonna tell you i'm not gonna be
bullied into not making cupcakes anymore
um in fact the second i'm done
with uh
with this podcast i might even go on
youtube and actually you know what's
been fascinating me all week
is trying to figure out how they get
filling in a [__] cupcake
how do you do it do you start to cook
the cupcakes and then take them out
and then [__] inject the [__] in the
middle
and that's so like loose that the other
thing then the cupcake is
this is cake enough that you can put it
in there
this is the kind of stuff that i think
about rather than looking at [__]
people getting upset
at what fathers of prisoners of war said
at the [__] white house you can't
tell me obama when he saw that guy's
beard coming up he didn't think oh
geez like what is this guy gonna say is
he gonna think i'm the butler who works
here first of all there's no way he
didn't think that that guy
that guy was like
textbook racist white guy's face
right
or at least like doomsday prepper
no idea who's president
he's got some [__] radio where he's
listening to uh i don't know what new
zealand
i know people i'm all over the [__]
place um
yeah so i've been getting in shape i've
been hiking
doing my pull-ups climbing the [__]
rope and then eating like a [__]
trying to eat like a champ
uh as i say that i have a pizza on the
way every once in a while you know
but uh i just got to go hard here for
the last few days and uh
i cannot wait to get this special done
so i can move on to my next hour and
enjoy my summer
and i've been going out to the clubs out
here in l.a like a maniac i did five
shows last night
i did
i think i took the night off before that
and i did two the night before that four
the night before that and it's funny
like i was gonna i was like i know i'm
just gonna do
all of my bits
in 15-minute chunks and you know what it
is i can't do it i start to do it and
then i just want to talk about the new
[__] which is the next [__] hour so
but i still think it's good to just be
out there doing it going out there
taking some swings
right staying in shop
i'm trying to anyways um
so
anyways i'm really looking forward to it
and we've sold a ton of tickets down in
atlanta and i really want to thank
everybody in advance for coming out to
uh
to to the uh to the taping and i hope i
give you a great show
all right and that's it oh by the way
i'm supposed to remind uh the listeners
of my uh podcast here if you want to
follow the podcast and uh the youtube
videos and the clips and all that type
of [__] all the stuff that i talk about
for you can follow the monday morning
podcast on twitter
at
the mm podcast
all right
and mmp in the mm podcast that's all
capitalized
and uh you know you get all the linus
updates all that [__] and all the all
things comedy things
um you know the all things comedy
networks we're gonna start trying to do
some live podcasts out here in la
and there's rumors that i might be
hosting one of the first couple
i've never done a live podcast where i
hosted it so um i will be letting i'm
doing a little teaser here i think that
that's gonna be happening in the
beginning of july so i'll let you guys
know about that um coming up
and uh
what else
i think that's it all right let's let's
get into the questions for this week
once again everybody thank you for
sending me your emails you really help
with the back nine here on the podcast
there
um all right
first one out of the gate hey bill my
girl my girlfriend doesn't like me
carrying around a knife
um
hey bill or nia bill and or nia
i have a problem with my girl i am an
ex-marine and trained for years
um before that with weapons
jesus christ you were already training
with weapons and then you became a
marine
see this is why you know i only talk
[__] on a comedy stage
because you never know who you're going
to run into right
as a result i am in shape and i carry a
knife wherever i go now my girl hates it
when we go out and i have i have it on
me it isn't a little pocket night it's
it's a foot long fixed blade oh [__]
this i gotta get nia hang on a second
let me press pause here
and with that the magic of the pause
button here we uh not only is the lovely
nia here welcome hi
um i also just wolfed down a pizza
we had a small pizza break yeah i did i
ordered a small pizza moment of silence
for this small pizza break
what a sad
sniff dog
i'm whitening you i don't i don't know
what this is why is this chronic break
instead of pizza oh
i added pizza so that
i don't know you know something i never
got into that west coast rap when it
first came out you don't like doggy
style though that that whole wee beep
[Music]
but snoop's first out like solo album is
awesome no he's great he's great
and he is aging he is aging better
than anybody he went seamlessly from
you know oh my god who is this young
hooligan into all of a sudden he was
uncle snoop and white people
just he said that was it he said
pistachios those uh pistachio he saw the
pistachios vaporizer pens he's like just
fully
embracing like i will sell anything as
long as it brings me money no i actually
wouldn't agree with that because both of
those things are awesome pistachios and
vapers
now if he was going to sell anything
there would be like you know clorox
bleach or some [__] in there just like
shaq sounds like what he used to do
nestle crunch bars which i thought was
kind of weird shaq lost all credibility
when he was in that little ass buick i
remember that
trying to say how comfortable it was and
then he did that stupid point
he was pointing at his friends who were
laughing at him going look at check
first of all you don't drive but when's
the last time was the last time he drove
a [__] buick yeah that's true you
know what junior high
junior high by the time he was in high
school he was a rapper though and he was
in like with leaders in the new school
and all those people
no i remember how's my ass taste
what
it's a sports thing
what are you talking about when kobe and
him didn't get along
really who said he said how does my
essay well then
colby allegedly went to the front office
said look either he goes or i go it was
very real housewife
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it wasn't because it was two
grown-ass men like professional
players i guess so anyways
so and by the way people we are going to
get to the guy who carries the knife
um
we'll get to it there's a reason i
called you in here oh okay um
so
the lakers were like all right well
we got two studs here and one of them's
like [__] 10 years younger than the
other or whatever it's all right so
we're eight years younger so we gotta so
they got rid of shaq shaq
went to the heat and i believe the next
year or the or the year after
either the very next year of the year
after he won a championship with the
heat okay and the lakers were
floundering at that point and uh so he
was just he so he
was at a club
and he was celebrating as you do and all
of a sudden a microphone was handed to
him
he started freestyle rapping
and came up with one and he was trashing
kobe basically saying that uh you know
you thought you could do it without me
now you can't so i went over here and i
won one with dwyane wade and the hook
was how's my ass tasted that's
disgusting
uh i think it was supposed to be
disgusting oh well then success yeah but
there's somebody shot shaquille jack is
still silly he's silly enough he plays
though
shaq yeah no i didn't think so he sits
in a giant [__] suit does he he
sounds like like that kind of that like
heat rub like my back hurts because i
bent over too many times right so let me
pick it up my
[__] with my bag
i was gonna say my giant slippers with
my [__]
shaquille logo embroidered in them
too wordy bill um
anyways let's let's get to this here uh
bill my girlfriend doesn't like me
carrying around a knife
all right i have a problem with my girl
i am an ex-marine and trained for years
before that with weapons
as a result i am in shape and i carry a
knife wherever i go stop bragging
maybe stop brandon
now [__] this everybody else is a fat
[__] out here this guy
he's learned how to defend himself
for the most part mia did you see the
people at brunch today
wow
so what though that's the most wow in
america and people who are in shape
really need to like get off their whole
[__] high horse about it like you
went to the gym congratulations
what are you talking about this guy's a
hero
all right anyway wait a minute wait a
minute back up
back up
back up i didn't say that everybody in
america wasn't you know couldn't lose a
couple
i'm just saying he's a guy who's
actually in shape so he says can we
continue please
i don't like how you already hate this
guy even when you hear what he's done
because i don't think he has a problem
with this girl i think he's a problem
with his ego
and his paranoia but let's continue see
this is why i bring you in this is so
into the female perspective
okay he goes now
and my girl hates it when we go out
and i have it on me meaning the knife it
isn't a little pocket knife it's a foot
long fixed blade knife
i can see
oh is this he has a little dick
he has a little dick i can seal it under
my shoulder
under my jacket she says i don't like to
feel it when i hug you
which is [__] we have thought about
this and i refuse to give it up because
it is an invaluable tool and it gives me
a small sense
of safety should i break up with her
cave and get rid
uh rid of it or lie and hide it in the
car oh my god if you are willing to lose
your girlfriend over inanimate [__]
object as i said in the beginning before
we got to the end of this [__]
question you've got more problems than
your girlfriend i don't know if you got
ptsd or whatever it is but if you're
seriously
asking bill if you should break up with
your girlfriend or put your [__]
knife away because it freaks her out
that you carry it under your shoulder
like some [__] renegade in some
goddamn crusty movie from the late 80s
then that's a serious problem can we
back up what was what was uh
pdst what is that ptsd
post traumatic stress disorder which is
a serious thing that a lot of veterans
suffer with so i don't i don't mean to
to belittle it if that's the thing that
you feel because you're a marine and you
went through [__] and dangerous this guy
this guy was in the weapons before that
clearly and that's the other thing too
that's what i mean like if it's really
like my knife or my girlfriend is that
sir is that a real question you know
what
i think you just came up one of the
great bumper stickers that you could
sell in a lot of rural areas of america
my knife or my girlfriend
and you just have some dude like
i don't know
is that really a question though sir
like that's what i mean is it really
equip my knife or my should i break up
with her just play along just act like
all of these are real it makes it so
much easier to get to the community
why
a woman hugging you and feeling a knife
that you keep concealed on your shoulder
at all times
is a little funny it's underneath it's
on it's like i understand that but do
you know what until somebody shows up
with a gun and he pulls out that night
he goes hey hey
i got a knife here
i will deflect these bullets like wonder
woman why do you have the knife sir do
you have ptsd
is that what it is do you feel like you
need to have it because of the [__] that
you went through in the marines which is
completely legitimate in which case well
you need to have a more it's legitimate
you need to talk to somebody about that
and then you need to talk to your
girlfriend why you feel like you need to
have it because why do you feel like you
need to have it he's never said in this
in this question at all why he feels
like he needs to carry a knife at all
times when he's going on date night with
his girl he's got the knife under like
his his blazer
that's not a little
bizarre that's a little excessive to you
first of all
even gun nuts aren't carrying that [__]
constantly listen first of all what
should be crazy out there in the streets
[Music]
you never know
when you might need an i mean
what is this like a foot long a foot
long night that he keeps hidden under it
like i mean at what point does it become
a sword
two feet
and he's talking about giving up the
knife or breaking up with his i mean the
real thing is the real thing is come on
the real thing is is a guy needs to get
out of this relationship
because if he's even remotely
considering
you know what yes break up with her and
spare her you're crazy
hey easy yes break up with her do her a
favor let her go because you clearly got
some [__] to work out and
you are questioning whether you should
keep a knife or you keep your
relationship can i give you something
instructions
no no you can't because this is not bill
gives me a constructive criticism hour
this is nia comes on the podcast and
gives her opinion hour so that's what
she's doing
well how about can i give a third person
how can i give you
can i give you
constructive criticism for a minute
30 seconds let me ask you this well
first of all don't put me on the clock
on my podcast i'll shut off your mic
um
that's my knife
your knife is your microphone that's
right it is it's my security blanket
your microphone or your wife listen let
me first of all listen i already
admitted that i like [__] make
cupcakes i don't need to go even further
in this thing
um i was very sweet and they were
delicious
okay
can i get to this
sure
when you make points on this podcast you
want people to hear them right
that's not you don't go you kind of went
like the way people make
points on the internet
where people go rather than just making
their point to help they'll just be like
hey [__] maybe if you that's how
people start when they're making a point
okay so
at which point
no cool-headed like you no no no no no
no your lead
right
just be really like even
tempered
and and fair handed perfect person
and just not like reactionary and
freaking out and screaming i was out in
the balcony i heard you screaming about
whatever the [__] you're screaming about
this week i was singing
it's the same thing
listen
this guy definitely uh he has some
security issues without a doubt
um
i don't know you know like
maybe he got stabbed when he was younger
and he was like that's never going to
happen to me again so now he's got a i
don't know that's why i said ptsd which
is a very legitimate thing wow would you
stop with your [__] catchphrase
psychological psychology ptsd
you watch anything about veterans or
anything it's a real serious [__]
issue for these guys
no but you're not a psychologist you're
sitting over here like dr joyce brothers
[Music]
i'll put your lab coat away you don't
need to be a psychologist to hear when
someone says should i keep my knife or
break up with my girlfriend to know that
something is seriously wrong
you know maybe i don't need to be a chef
to know that the toast is burnt well let
me oh oh snap bam oh jesus
hey wait a second what if he sent it via
his [__] phone he's typing with his
thumb so he had you know because one
other hand is on his [__] knife
that's still a problem
well let me ask you this though what if
uh you know you like a hard body right
you like hugging on somebody that's in
shape this guy is in shape then what do
you need a knife doesn't the knife
because uh yeah what do you mean what do
you need knife for because we're made
out of 90 water
okay you could stab if you hit me if you
[__]
were able to [__] make a stabbing
motion okay fast enough with the straw
you kill me
okay that's real talk that's real that's
real talk song so what are you doing if
a tornado picks up a box full of straws
and some god forsaken diner in the
middle of nebraska
okay
you better hope you're already in your
[__] bathtub with the legs on what
are you getting at with the whole i like
a hard body what does it have to do with
a knife i'm saying don't you guys okay
you like a guy who's in shape yeah
rugged he seems like he can protect you
yeah and he's [__] you know he's
ready to be a bad you know bad guy in
like a steven seagal movie he's ready
he's ready i'd rather his body be a
lethal weapon not feeling like he has to
carry one
yeah but nobody's body is a lethal
weapon a lot like aren't like i don't
know kung fu masters and yeah those are
movies
aren't there people in real life who can
like have their their hand like floyd
mayweather that jackass can he have his
why don't you like him with all his
white cars you know why i don't like
floyd mayweather i'm not getting into it
i actually don't know why you don't like
floyd mayweather we didn't talk about
this we didn't talk about how just just
can you just him and his relationship
with women that's all i'm gonna say just
google it no no don't no no no no no
come on just google it what what does he
do what he bangs a lot of women he
should be he's the champ
bang if you mean him around yes the
champ gets yes
banging as in beating them up sure he
bangs a lot of women hey i tell jokes at
home i mean everybody brings their job
home oh my god
you really need to stop
now how do you know he hits his women
how do i watch every one of his boring
pay-per-view fights and get sucked in
every time as he poo poo poo poo poo and
[__]
scores his way through this oh you mean
as he comes out with like a circus
leading him out and flanked by justin
bieber and lil wayne
that guy
turned down for what turned out for what
um why
it's me and bill's new favorite slime oh
it's a [__] great song
you know what i love about that lyric it
reminds me of though i love those
richard pryor bits
where he would be talking to other
characters and you couldn't hear what
they were saying but you knew by what he
was saying you could tell what the other
people were saying i love that [__] and
what i love about that lyric turned down
for what is your nose
you see the party you see him having a
good time and you can just hear hey why
don't you turn it and him sticking his
head out the window turn down for what
and you know what there's no answer yeah
for what from what yeah yeah i like
being turned up little wayne makes sense
little john oh little john
get your lils correct which one's little
wayne oh that's the guy with the he
drank like [__] nyquil for five years
then i had to go to jail look like a
look like a meerkat in that suit
remember that that [__] look on his
face that is the look of somebody about
ready to lose their freedom i hope i
never have that look um that's there's
no [__] way to go to court when your
freedom is on the line all of your
[__]
whatever it is
uh when the verdict's coming in you have
this [__] are they gonna stick me in a
[__] cage i can't you know i i can't
uh
i can't imagine
ever being the defendant in a [__]
trial where at the end of this i'm
either gonna
go free
or they're going to put me in a [__]
cage
i just i can't even i can't imagine that
you lost me
what were we talking i was you weren't
listening i was i was talking about
little wayne little john and then you
said lil wayne little wayne and i said
guy who drank the nightclub and he had
that look at that little mirror
meerkat when he was sitting there in his
suit
please find the innocent suit that he
was wearing
and his hipster glasses that he put on
he looked terrified
as i would be he looked you know i'm not
terrified
i do too i'm not saying i don't love the
i mean i don't know him i'm just saying
i do love him i like that one where he
was the doctor
oh yeah dr carter we have another
patient doctor and he's like ah jesus
christ
you sound like that grizzled vet i ain't
got time for this [__] he went nick
nolte on that track three fantastic rap
um legalzoom everyone america was built
by innovators and dreamers
people like thomas edison and henry ford
laid the foundation for our country
these days it's the inventors and the
entrepreneurs all around us like you
that keep our country running by fueling
the job market and economy this month
legalzoom celebrates innovation by
helping you launch your dream apply for
a patent to secure your inner your
invention register your trademark to
protect your products and services
incorporate or form an llc and launch
your business visit legalzoom.com and
use discount code burr burr they'll
provide the personal attention you need
and help take care of all the details
they've helped over a million businesses
get started
right
and they've received an a-plus from the
better business bureau celebrate
innovation with legalzoom today and get
a special price on trademark copyright
or provisional patent applications by
using the discount code bur burr at
checkout legalzoom provides legal help
through independent attorneys and
self-help but they are not a law firm
legalzoom.com discount code burr
and lastly but not leastly hulu plus
everyone you've probably tried hulu on
your computer hulu plus is so much more
with hulu plus you can watch current
seasons
uh episodes of your favorite shows like
modern family the daily show and scandal
and watch every episode of shows like
nashville lost and doctor who
uh you get ad-free movies and kid shows
too now more than ever there's so much
to watch take total control with hulu
plus to stream these shows and thousands
more as much as you want whenever you
want hula plus works on your computer
your smartphone tv
roku apple tv i'm sorry your smart tv
not smartphone smart tv roku apple tv
xbox playstation pretty much
any streaming device you already own you
can even watch on your phone or ipad
well i guess they can then huh while on
the train at work at the dentist or in
the bathroom you can even block off a
data bench
you also get to uh to access originals
that you cannot get anywhere else check
out the new show deadbeat a comedy about
a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost you
can binge on all 10 episodes starting
april 9th for only 7.99 a month get your
shows anytime anywhere that's like a
quarter a day come on folks sign up now
right now sign up at huluplus.com
or click the banner on my website and
get two weeks full access completely
free that's a whole extra week more with
this special offer when you sign up at
huluplus.com
bill
oh wait i've got the ending so get with
it and start streaming tv now with hulu
plus
i'm the worst
okay all right weight loss dog pox and
banging there we go all right billy boy
he goes i got no nickname for you i
don't worry don't worry about it thanks
for the podcast
i'm a sales rep and use your podcast to
de-stress is that a word
uh don't you do that with jeans
distress
on the monday
afternoon drive home oh nice six months
ago my company laid me off and i've used
your podcast to fat mate fat shame
myself
and work out during the day i love it
dude fat shaming works no it doesn't yes
it does i guess it does does for me i
stand in the mirror shirtless and i just
go look what you did
look what you did you piece of [__]
nobody's gonna love you the next thing
you know i'm out there eating kale
jogging down the street with my white
legs
um he said i've dropped 40 pounds can we
talk about how you're dressed for a
sport that would like never have you why
are you dressed like that no because i
was going to go on a bike ride
you're matching you actually look pretty
cute i have to say
that i mean no guy wants to look cute
oh all right guys oh my god you look
cute you do you look cute i would i
would i would give you a second glance
at the gym if you were wearing your
little nike outfit christ really that
matches and what am i supposed to be
thrilled by that yeah yeah
oh [__] you'd give me a second glance
yeah yeah you should be happy
all right consider yourself looking i
don't like your mint chocolate chips
[__] colored sweater this is rag and
bone okay okay listen to the real
fashion [__] i've dropped 40 pounds and
it's been great from 260 to 220 and size
4 42 pants that's the size 36. nice good
for you how to [__] wait a minute how
are you sized how are you 220 pounds
size 36 pants
how does that work 42 to a third this
guy's got to be jacked he's on the juice
he's got [__] he's got giant
shoulders 80 pound shoulders
um he go anyway so here's my dilemma he
goes i have a lab
not a pot a lab golden retriever mix
and we go to the park near my house
every day to play fetch off the leash
there is usual the usual there is the
usual suspects of about 10 to 15 people
that bring their dogs out to play i live
in a slightly unsafe city parentheses
baltimore the wire yeah wait a minute
didn't they shoot the wire there yes
yeah slightly
um
all baltimore yeah not all baltimore
yeah you got you got the [__]
waterfront that's sort of nice for half
a second
although didn't what's his face
he had a meeting down there one time one
of the episodes oh
the guy you like the english guy
on that show i don't know what his
[__] name is
his name on the show though was um
sturgis
striker
yeah wait spalding sterling no
all right let's move on
um and last week we were outside
discussing
stringer string her belly yep i did put
some new words in my head then i can
remember and last week we were outside
discussing the group of kids groups of
kids on bikes that are grabbing women's
asses
while jogging in the park
so one guy starts telling the women to
grab the kid that does that and hold him
there until the police come oh yeah that
that's really safe and realistic for
women to do
is that sarcasm yes that is sarcasm keep
reading
well just because he addresses it in the
next sentence all right don't [__]
order me around on my what's wrong with
you nothing
what jesus christ um he goes i think you
can see the
keep reading i've made my comment
continue
you were drunk with power
um he goes i think you can see the
danger here of anyone any one adult
grabbing a 14 to 16 year old kid and
think the other kids will just ride away
you're going to get beat down and
probably hit in the head with the brick
sounds like the beginning of a death
wish movie
um so this same guy who by the way is a
hedge fund manager and knows everything
starts telling me all the fights he's
been in
uh he goes i'll buy each listener on of
this podcast a beer if he's even been in
one fight
he goes so his wife is there and
everyone is listening he says i want to
fight one time with just my mouth so
before you can say anything else i say
what did you do blow them
he goes well everyone laughs
he can't really say anything and he
storms off gets about 10 yards away and
tells his wife she has to come home
she throws me a wink and says that was
hysterical i think you hurt his feelings
oh
jesus christ doors opening and other
doors closing 36 pants he goes i found
out a couple of days later
that i'm going back to work and i'm
being recla relocate he's going to say
can i bang her before i leave that's
what i'm guessing
back to work and i'm being relocated
over a thousand miles away what's the
problem well his wife
his oh he wrote it wrong well his wife
is a hot piece of ass and has started
sending me facebook's messages and texts
oh text what do you mean text when she
gets your number i skipped a part of
that story sir saying she wants to sleep
with me before i leave they have no kids
and she showed me divorce papers that
she is willing she's waiting to file
uh after he gets his next bonus check in
august normally i'm a pretty upstanding
dude he's got to build up credibility
people like me in the community i've
recently lost weight i have a lab golden
retriever mix and i go to the dog park
he wants to [__] this guy's wife uh he
goes i don't believe in crossing lines
but this one feels different i'm moving
within the next six weeks what should i
do with thanks and go [__] yourself nia
i'm gonna pass it over to you
you know good and goddamn well you need
to stay away from that woman
all right you're doing well you lost
weight you got nice little one-liners
you know how to put people in their
place
walk away you'll find somebody to [__] a
thousand miles away where you get really
okay relocated okay this is not the last
piece of hot ass that you're gonna come
across so
relax your so what you're saying just
tie yourself on the back for the good
line and the facts are getting attention
from hot pieces of ass who are looking
to
take their husbands for all their worth
before they divorce them and start
banging the smart ass at the dog park be
happy for that but you can [__] somebody
else so what you're saying
is it's like when columbus sailed over
to america which was actually down to
cuba i believe before he started
chopping off people's hands because they
couldn't find gold for his fillings okay
um they saw branches
right in the water
that let them know that land was coming
like that was a good sign so you're
saying this this is just a hot piece of
ass floating by
letting them know that he's he's about
ready to get on [__] island absolutely
yes that's exactly what i'm way to go
all right so just just walk away i'm
sure it's very flattering
but you already you already humiliated
the guy you did you did your you did
your work that was a great line what did
you do blow them that's fantastic
and she's been waiting for a guy to come
along to put her husband into his in his
place and all that stuff so yeah good
for you but no don't don't be that guy
walk away all right you'll find somebody
else
i say do it all right fame
no don't do it you know you're the voice
of reason good you're absolutely right
because you have no idea why she wants
to do that you know because she might in
an argument and be like oh yeah and you
remember that guy at the dog park well i
[__] him exactly he was better than
you and then all of a sudden this guy
sounds crazy
why is she showing you divorce papers
and like i'm going to divorce him as
soon as he gets his next bonus check
stay away from crazy
stay
that's tp right there what's that toxic
[__]
[Music]
it is
yeah all right
fame
dear bill i am an inspiring actor and
have been uh and have been for quite
some time now
i am an inspiring actor and have been
for quite some time now i am the worst i
don't know where to pause in sentences
he goes i'm not good at reading out loud
really
what do you tell me next i don't tan
well
um
your forearms do pretty good but the
rest of you is like
what would you want me to walk down the
street in a [__] speedo
i i went to a laguardia i went to a
laguardia high school a school for
performing arts
live forever to get school
um in pursuit to become an actor
while there i met
i don't say names here
i don't do names on here he goes you may
know him from a couple of movies he's in
now because you never know what he's
going to say okay um he was an arrogant
jerk see
that talked about he was going to get
out of high school and go straight into
acting without a care in the world you
see
his father is a famous photographer for
a magazine so
he already had a shoe in to break into
the industry
well what's he supposed to do not use it
high school was a while ago and now i'm
schlepping it doing student films and
extra work while he's rocking a 1.2
million
instagram followers because his movie
just came out how do i not feel bitter
and resentful i know i'm not supposed to
want fame as much as i do and i'm coming
off
really bitter and resentful but it's
just how i feel that's honest yeah he's
being honest you can't get mad at that
this is what you do yeah you say god
bless him and his uh his his success and
you stop stalking him on the internet i
was just about to say stop following him
on instagram stop worrying about what
he's doing how many followers he has and
i know the movie that you're referring
to did incredibly well this weekend hey
hey let's let's not give it away
let's not give it away but
just
maleficent millicent
maleficent
male efficient
um but but let it go
this is your thing all right work go to
class here's the deal take your parts we
can get in get your reel together
do all the things that an actor is
supposed to do also you're not in a what
what is you what did you call yourself
i'm an aspiring actor you're not an
aspiring actor you are an actor so let's
let's change the way we talk about
ourselves you are an actor okay just
because you're not in this
billion dollar making film doesn't
you're an actor okay do your thing don't
worry about anybody else
we're all surrounded by people who are
going to be more successful than us
that's the way that it goes you don't
know where this guy is going to end up
you only have yourself to worry about so
just just let it go
you know i know that's hard but
you know who cares what he's doing the
other guy that we can't say his name
no you don't
we all get jealous we all get
i never got bitter but i it was
definitely when i was early on
and i wasn't you know getting anywhere
that's the time when you are most
susceptible to being jealous envious and
resentful and that type of thing but i
never got the bitter but i definitely
were was looking at people
going like oh [__] i started before this
person and they're there and i'm here
and what the [__] am i doing wrong and
and uh oh this person is killing it and
you know you know [__] that person
blah blah blah blah it just it's a bunch
it's a waste wasted energy you just you
just gotta believe that you're gonna get
what the [__] you're gonna get so put
all that energy into your work yeah
and uh keep your eyes down when you see
his big billboard in times square
it's [__] it's a problem
it's a brutal business
but then that is a great question i mean
you know what because people you know
i'm sure people at work they get passed
over and somebody else gets the [__]
job or there was somebody in in hr that
you wanted to bang and be like oh i
can't [__] somebody at work that's
against the rules and somebody else
moved in and they got him and then they
both quit the job and you see him
disappearing into the sunset and you're
sitting there did this happen to you no
you're being standing over there i paint
pictures crying
that's all i do twitter
builder i paint pictures i make cupcakes
i paint pictures
all right dilemma all right bill would
you rather have would you rather have
drumroll he says
a daughter who's a hoe
or a gay son
who's also a hoe what the [__] is this
[__] homophobic sexist ass ridiculous
question
a daughter who's a hoe or a gay son
who's a hope
this is so offensive on so many levels
like i can't even i won't even so that's
all you
okay
well here's the thing nia people have to
be allowed to be homophobic why
because that's how you get it out of you
that's like saying you know you
shouldn't be feeling obviously not into
fat shaming but this guy can't [__]
[__] shaming i'm all for it
no i'm not saying that like no this is
the problem
this is the [__] problem what is the
problem the problem is is you're already
enlightened yeah okay and somebody else
isn't enlightened and the way to get
them there is not the [__] all over them
you got to extend the [__] olive
branch
oh god becomes more sarcasm
i have to be tolerant for like the
ignorant [__] right because they're
the ones that are misunderstood they're
the ones that need an extra helping hand
in this world because the world is so
hard for them that's right because
everyone else is so like pc this is why
nothing gets solved and the people who
are unenlightened they just get left
behind they just get left behind all
these poor ignorant [__] like they
don't let's all like help lift them up
not the people who are truly suffering
from with that ignorance
listen
none of that got that guy any closer
to
first of all he might just be you
calling him doesn't help either i'm not
coddling the guy yeah you are you cuddle
a lot of ignorant [__] in the name
of comedy and i'm sick of it
jesus christ
look you do
all right well let me ask you this
you know somebody says something
homophobic on tv and then they get fired
from a show for saying something
homophobic and you immediately side with
them why is that i don't side with them
yeah you do you take that you you you go
with like the sympathy angle rather than
the people who are actually offended by
it you're like well wait a minute now
let's figure out why that's not what i'm
saying you don't even listen to what i'm
saying you're so you're so on your
[__] soapbox of how goddamn right you
are
that you're immediately assuming that
i'm advocating homophobia i'm not
why are you advocating i'm advocating
that when somebody's [__] homophobic
to just go in and then take their job
from them how does that help that person
with their homophobia do you think they
then go home and go like oh now i get it
they don't they become worse so if you
want to solve the [__] problem and i
believe that when they do that it isn't
as much about stopping whatever the
thing is a sexist comment homophobic
anything what it is is it is it showing
the power that your group has you shut
the [__] up or we're firing you so what
you do is all you do is you create all
of that ignorance to go underground
you're not telling them to shut the [__]
up what you're telling them is that let
me finish can i can i finish my point
please finish my point oh you can't you
you're what you're telling us is that
they don't have a
right to just be have a platform and
spew that kind of intolerance
i'm not saying that you don't say [__]
up you don't say anything ever about no
you just you're not it's not okay
when you have can i finish my [__]
point for the love of christ
okay what i'm saying is you're not
giving them a platform i'm not saying
that they don't get reprimanded
or anything like that but to take their
[__] job what you've done is you've
taken a person whose ignorance was here
and now you're going to add way more to
that
and you're going to stir up all these
other [__] people i'm telling like
the way i feel to get rid of all of that
[__] is you got to let people say the
stuff and then you have to sit down them
rationally and you can't come at hey you
ignorant [__]
sexist [__] [__]
maybe if you were enlightened like then
then your enlightened point comes after
all of that [__] they don't they don't
hear it at that point you fire somebody
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
come less sexist or anything like that
all you've done is taking away you took
away their ability to earn a [__]
living that's all you did and they're
gonna become even more resentful and
they're gonna have [__] kids and what
are they going to pass it on to i'm not
saying that you can sit down with these
people and actually rationalize them to
to to a different place
okay but some of them you can
but if you fire all of them and you
scold all of them and all that [__] and
as i've said in my act a zillion [__]
times if everybody's conversations were
recorded would anybody have a job on
monday i'm just i'm [__] sick of
everybody jumping on on on a soapbox or
all gathering around to watch somebody
take a [__] beatdown and completely
ignoring
all all of your own [__] faults i
just don't think that that the the uh
crucify him
angle to all of this [__] is is going to
help is going to help anybody now
there's definitely situations where like
take take like the clippers owner
okay now what that guy is doing
is is like he's affecting like the
entire nba he's infecting the entire
[__] product so you have to get rid
of that guy okay he's one of the owners
of the league but i think like a guy
just a guy on espn
okay if he makes an ignorant comment is
a great opportunity to sit down with
that guy and then watch the guy
hopefully honestly go through some sort
of a journey you could turn that into a
[__] show you could actually have a
guy rather than come out and do the
usual horseshit you know uh
what i said was ignorant and blah blah i
mean
i could [__] wing an apology for
every [__] offensive thing at this
point i've seen every [__] apology
you're just going out there giving lip
service because you're trying to get
your [__] money back
you know what i mean but to actually sit
sit down and say say to talk to somebody
who actually thinks like being gay is a
choice
to maybe trying to try to get through
you could maybe just get 10 of the
people onto this side
rather than pushing them all they're
pushing their face in the mud hey you're
a bad [__] person
[__] your job [__] all this i'm not
saying that that they shouldn't be
disciplined but this whole thing that
when somebody does something like that
this person might have just wrote it
just thought i thought this was funny
and and they didn't they didn't
understand
i remember a few years ago supposed to
go in there and like take their their
hand into my hand and sit down and be
like okay now listen
like they're my child now i know you
thought this was funny but this is why
it's offensive i'm supposed to i'm
supposed to do that now
no because what you're doing is still
condescending now you're treating him
like a child
now this is what you did so what are you
proposing sitting down and talking to
people
actually having an ad like that [__]
that mark cuban got in trouble for was
was [__] horseshit the guy was being
honest what what are you talking about
he got in trouble for being honest and
he had to apologize for being honest
for he was talking about the clippers
owner
and what he started doing was started
talking he started talking about his own
issues which i thought was a really
courageous thing to do where he was
saying like look you know
um the world that we live in he goes
when i walk down the street if i'm
walking down the street at night and i
see a black guy with his hoodie up i'm
crossing the street if i then see a
white guy with a shaved head and a bunch
of tattoos on his neck and blah blah i'm
crossing the street again where he
[__] up was he said the hoodie thing
which made everybody think trayvon yeah
but what he was saying was was the
beginning of this unbelievable [__]
conversation that never happens in the
media it all is the person says the
[__] thing then they get in trouble
they lose their [__] job and then
they disappear and then that's it and
everybody learn all you learn is oh
don't say that on television
like this whole elimination of words
like if we eliminate the word
like but people don't think like you're
not gonna think [__] oh i would think
that that's racial slur but now that i
can't say it i don't think those
thoughts
it's [__]
i don't know if it's childish or like
moronic i understand it where people
don't want to see that or hear it on
television but you're not helping the
problem
what you're actually doing
but i think what we're doing doesn't
[__] work go on the internet nia and
look at the look at the level of this
type of [__] out there
it's [__] off the charts yeah i know
all right so
what you're doing when you eliminate
these words and you have all these
[__]
uh uh fire the person and all that what
which if you have half a [__] brain
you just learn okay don't say this don't
say that don't say that and then what
you can basically do is you can safely
get across the minefield without blowing
yourself up now while you still think
all that ignorant [__] while you still
won't hire this person while you still
won't associate with this person while
you still feel this way
while you're still standing your ground
you can get through all of that that
entire [__] maze because
through watching through this simple
game of these are the words you don't
[__] say these are the words you can
say all of that horseshit it doesn't
change anything that's in your heart
that's all cerebral
these are good words these are bad words
and you can still have all of that awful
[__] in your heart and not to mention
everybody has [__] up everybody has
[__] issues everybody has issues
they do you make those those people who
say i don't make a lot of those people
who say i don't see color are [__] i
hate when people full of [__] i hate
when people yeah what are you are you
asian i can't tell i don't i don't see
ridiculous when people say that no i i
agree with that no and then people also
make assumption they go oh your wife is
african-american you can't be racist you
can't have any racist it's also [__]
yeah it's also [__] i at night when
i'm at night i used to be in my act that
everybody at night is [__] racist
because you're scared and you're trying
to get to your [__] car so whatever
you see you think the worst of them can
i also just which goes back to that mark
cuban point when he's talking about
walking about to bring that up because i
think can i also just say that i think
it's hilarious that anyone would think
that mark cuban walks down the street
anywhere if he's not being like
chauffeured in a maybach or like flying
in a private plane like mark cuban was
the last time you walked down the street
and we're saying no he's a cool guy he's
a cool guy he's come out to a couple
comedy shows
he just walks in the back hangs in the
back come on you know him i i've seen
him on tv i have seen i've i've seen him
where's the t-shirt and they've got the
bed head i've seen yes i've seen mark
cuban
you saw him in a club in vegas yep
was that the time i was there nope
the [__] did you go to vegas with mark
cuban i didn't go to vegas did he fly
you in
no coach no first place if you flew in
first class i'm gonna [__] have to
what are you doing i have her trained
anywhere like i'm in the plane all right
i'm not anyway no it's not that's not
the point all right can i answer this
dilemma is not the point all right yeah
what's what's the dilemma oh are you
actually going to like go back and
answer this question
a daughter who's a hoe or a gay son
who's a hoe
the nuance and like the lesson that
we're supposed to learn from this
ridiculous well if you get off your
[__] high horse what he's getting out
there is the amount of people that say
they're not homophobic but wouldn't want
to have a gay son
is that true
he's comparing having a daughter who's a
[__]
to having a gay son like like that's the
same thing and then he's also a [__]
you know
so i i it's it's like to me this is like
the thing i can't get mad at this is is
is the honesty what's the matter what do
you point here i hear something coming
out from here
yeah oh how long has that been going on
i don't know ah [__] why don't why isn't
there just like a daughter who's a hoe
or a son who's
no because if a guy is
a [__] he's considered like a stud
right so he doesn't even enter the
equation which is which is right by the
way this is why which is right by the
way which is right what first of all
hold the mic up which is right what if
if a guy
be a son
is going out there crushing it he's a
stud
and if your daughter is going out there
crushing it yeah she's also a stud no
she's not no she is no she isn't see
this is what i'm talking about this
question is so [__] offensive it's so
offensive can i tell you what daughter
who's a hoe or gay son who's also a hoe
like [__] you well what if he's like 20
19 i don't care i would say the exact
same thing if i had my 19 or 20 year old
son all right
all right
stuff listen to me
i'll tell you why
the the the sun crushing it
this is an old bit of mine and i'm gonna
do it for you here in the pocket because
it takes skill as a guy
here it is here it is you just exist as
a woman and you can get laid is that
what it is and so men should be
applauded for their ability to stick it
in a girl congratulations men of the
world
you got laid you know what this is
people you know what this is ray for you
gold star for men because you're able to
like somehow convince the woman to have
sex with you wow you're a real [__]
don juan over there
this is it now just imagine just how
hard it is for me to talk to you to even
get a word in on this podcast now
imagine i'm trying to [__] you
that's what it is and i remember a long
time ago when i was talking to you i
said okay let's switch to let's turn the
tables you come you were talking about
the the dumb [__] that guys say to you
yeah in a bar and i said all right let's
turn the tables let's say i have control
of my [__]
sexuality right that's actually my
sexual
i don't know who i like
um
in some days
you have control over your sexuality yes
i do honey thank you snap to the north
and to the south
um
12 and six honey
um oh no no what what if like
what was the scenario i said if i i had
control of my sex drive and you did it
you told me and i said for you to come
in and start hitting on me and you know
what you were [__]
i was awful you were awful
and then the greatest line ever was i
just sat there going like yeah whatever
and i was just doing all that type and
you go you're making this difficult on
purpose and i said yeah welcome to my
world
and that's what it was oh
so hard to be a guy i'm not saying it's
hard to be a guy i'm saying in that situ
first of all that's the entire thing
that's what all feminism is based in
it's difficult to be a woman and your
your [__] equation the feminist
equation is is basic it's like what okay
lying in a bed it's easier for a guy to
lie on a mattress nothing
about feminism you know nothing so for
you to sit here and try to act like you
know what feminism is and what it means
you need to just stop all right then
i'll be more general women complaining
it's it's harder for for a woman to lose
weight it's harder for us to sit in a
chair
it's harder for us you don't need to
speak about things that you don't know
anything about but i realize that hasn't
stopped you before
yeah you've been interrupting me for a
[__] half an hour going on your
goddamn the podcast so what do you want
from me you want me to just sit here and
be like uh-huh oh i thought you were
gonna be an adult i i thought i was
being an adult i thought we were having
an adult conversation you weren't being
you weren't being an adult you were
[__] talking over me
i'm the blowhard welcome to my world
oh touche
this is why it works
between us no shut up
you know i'm so pissed i made you those
cups you know i should have made those
things right brought them in here look
at you oh that's so sweet just mushed
them right in your face how would you
like that nia why are you recalling like
an old bit of yours i'm not is that an
old [__] yes it is
what bit was that one that's kind of
it's kind of a play on the the punching
the muffins but
those are muffins this is a totally
different bit i feel like comedians like
bitching over a joke mine's different
mine are cupcakes all right okay are you
actually going to finish that gatorade
you're going to leave one swallow in it
stick in the refrigerator
[__] weirdo
you have like [__] 15 things in the
refrigerator that'll have one bite or
one sip left i know
i know it's ridiculous i don't know i
just why don't you go stick another miso
soup in there
until the [__]
tapioca whatever the [__] your tofu
turns green
i know i don't know why i don't just
finish it and they don't you know what
you finish the cheese anytime i [__]
get those nice [__] slices of cheese
to my salami sandwich i maybe get one
sandwich with cheese on it and then i
come back and i'm like where the [__] is
all the cheese yeah and then you put on
your oh i did something wrong so i'm to
make a cute face now
yeah
i guess i eat it well
i told you you can't have cheese in the
house with me all right can we answer
this question here neil what would you
rather have would rather have a daughter
who's a hoe
or a gay son who's also a hoe i would
rather not have a child that would even
ask questions like this not an option
it's either or
nope
not answering oh you're taking your ball
and you're going home that's right
why don't you answer with them
i know what you're going to say
i'd rather have a gay son i knew it
because at least he's a guy getting
something yeah
why both you and this person dance ask
this question what are you talking about
having a gay son be great first of all
you could t he could teach you how to
keep your abs well into your 50s
as long as he's out there practicing
safe sex
right i'm assuming they did he's a top
oh because you're you're gay when we
and if he's gay you want him to be a top
that's actually a funny line for a
[__] character in a movie my son's
gay oh he's a top yeah but he's like
he's excited it's a different it's so
until he's still crushing it right
ridiculous
this is like in true detective when
woody harrelson's character when his
like chickens come home to roost so to
speak and his daughter is caught with
the two guys in the car and he starts
freaking out at her and saying like
what's it like being the captain of the
diversity [__] team or whatever and he's
out there whoring around like constantly
this is like the exact same scenario
how
where he feels like he's entitled to do
all this [__] to [__] all the women that
he wants to and can
and yeah when his daughter is doing the
same thing he's freaking out at her and
she's getting like grounded there's no
skill involved
you there is no skill involved it has
nothing to do with skill okay it is you
don't have to talk you see you don't
have to just demand that you don't have
to convince a guy to [__] you like it's
a sport like what do you have to do what
do you have to do
what do you have to do
show a little leg yeah i come in with my
red chest there you think i'm beating
them off me i'm not
i've got to put on my gloves i got to
put on my big boy pants
and come up with an opening line you're
a performer who's out on stage don't try
to act like it's so hard for you to get
laid okay don't don't perpetrate this
myth that it's so difficult for you
you're actually perpetrating a myth for
all of you people aspiring comedians or
entertainers
if you want the easy [__] you
uh eddie murphy did it a long time ago
all you do have to do is sing
comedians get laid left and right they
get laid left and right no matter how
ridiculous douchebag and dirtbag but
here's the thing here's the thing though
laid left here's the thing how many
groupies are lining up at the comedy
there are comedy groupies there are
commentaries there are
comedy oh my god when do they show up
when you're finally playing a stadium
you go down to a coffee house with a
[__] ukulele okay and somebody's
blowing you and you know what when
you're [__] sets over no no when when
your [__] sets over you don't have to
keep playing the ukulele as a comedian
you're funny on stage when you get off
you got to keep [__] you got to keep
the plate spinning yeah you have to
still be an entertaining person in order
to be considered worthwhile that's
everyone's issue no no no no but you can
be some mopey coffee house guy all the
leaves are brown
and the sky is gray right and then get
off stage and just sit there with your
shoulder slump and they want to take
care of you next thing you know they're
buying your groceries
you never heard the guns and roses they
had like a whole [__] little harem of
[__] chicks paying for paying for
their [__]
why
because those guys seem helpless in any
way shape or form
did axel rose come off as helpless and
slash helplessness anyone look at those
guys as like oh they need a mommy i
don't [__] know i don't know i'm just
saying though just don't don't put it
out there that you're gonna become a
comedian
this certainly get laid there's certain
comics you have to be a good community
let's put it that way no but there's
also like be funny
yeah yeah believe me
believe me i have not had the groupies
trust me
i have a bunch of meathead guys who come
out to my show
and the occasional like you know
psychotic woman
okay
lately i've been turning the corner a
little bit but i got to tell you like
david for a while there you did have
kind of the the crazy
chicks that were coming up to you
afterward you did have a good period of
that well yeah because i was a i was an
angry believe it or not people i was
actually way more angry on stage back
day so i think i scared a lot of them
away
um
but no i found like that me
this is the deal
this this is what i found
with as a as a [__]
uh a male comic
if you do want to get laid after the
shows i found the comics who talk about
sex a lot
you know and then also then there's the
other ones
who have like that slumber party energy
you know that oh my god you guys if you
have like that vibe as a straight dude
that you're pretty much in there right
you're pretty much in that but the rest
of us the rest of us yeah you still got
you gotta kind of work it's it's
annoying i actually i actually actually
have to like work at it and like
you know
oh god you're so embarrassing
you paid
what are you coming off of this oh wow
do you have to wait yeah yeah i bust my
[__] ass excuse me when's the last
time i paid for a drink yeah
since i've been with you yes 10 years
yes
yeah otherwise if i'm not with you and
i'm out i buy my own drinks yeah thank
you very much oh every woman's a hero in
their stories
you are your main you guys are all here
uh
i will buy and pay for stuff
oh the ladies independent you [__]
throw your hands up but then when the
divorce happens i'm just a girl
yeah i really know what you guys yeah
you're some bitter divorced guy that's
gone through the ringer when it hasn't
even [__] happened to you
well it's happened to a lot of my
friends yeah and so so therefore it's
happened to you right so you're you've
not you've never you've never said i
never said it about what people go
through and divorce that's good when did
i say that happen to me
you act like it's happened to you the
way you talk about divorce and this and
that how women do this and women do that
how come they never talk about it you
never hear them talk about it you don't
well here's something for you if i can
only wait for your ass if i can only
talk about
what i've actually done
that would make you
that would be like
i'd be have like eight subjects i mean
what do i do i tell [__] jokes i go
to the airport
you know
so then what you can talk about a whole
bunch of subjects that you've maybe read
up on or know people have talked about
you went off on the whole gay thing
you're not gay
no i'm not but so where do you get off
telling me what like what subjects i can
and can't talk about touche huh oh
that's even a two shady with two shades
we're gonna end on a tie let's end on a
tie let's end on a tie oh we had a happy
ending everybody
all right that's the podcast for this
week
uh
that's it uh please if anybody if you're
in the atlanta area we got a couple more
rows to sell at the tabernacle uh
for my my next special on june 20th and
um
what else what else what else what else
all things comedy and that type of thing
my podcast network
nah i want to say something but i don't
want to say you know everybody knows
what the [__] happened this weekend and
i'm really shook up about it and yeah i
don't know what i get keep getting
conflicting reports and that type of
thing and i i feel just keep yeah yeah
and i i don't i don't i don't like i
don't like doing that because then they
[__] they they you know and so and so
had this to say and it becomes like a
[__]
a career move let me get more twitter
followers because of somebody else's
[__]
tragic nights
people that you know so it's not it's
not [__] though
it's sincere exactly all right okay
that's the podcast for this week i'll
talk to you [__] now
you